j'ai fait mon premier saut j'étais
ultra concentré en fait et quand je me
suis posé je suis je sais pas si ça m'a
depuis sept ans perrine sanchez passe
son temps à regarder le monde barreaux
pourtant au départ rien ne prédisposait
alors la jeune volleyeuse à la chute
libre
c'est en regardant les performances de
sa soeur que lenny l'antenne a voulu
vivre ses sensations uniques
le fait de pouvoir se déplacer dans le
ciel volet de pouvoir les un endroit à
un autre de tête façon comme je lé
décidé cette cette possibilité-là de
voler
c'est perrine a connu une ascension
fulgurante
championne du monde de vol relatif à 4
devant les américaines en décembre
dernier à 28 ans l'a surnommé pépettes
déploie ses ailes dans le ciel avec une
toute autre ampleur
maintenant nos quatre étudiants de
d'anciennes ans ce qui met à l'eau
qu'elle a passé le cap de la nouvelle
arrivée qui a fait sa place et là
maintenant donc elle va avoir un rôle
aussi un petit peu de le leadership avec
laurence pour accueillir les
nouvelle dans ces grandes compétitions
se jugeant sur dimanche cette
kinésithérapeute se jette dans le vide
uniquement par amour de l'action
la fédération internationale refuse en
attribué de l'argent aux vainqueurs et
aux médaillés et à l'air libre
cela donne ça attention à l'indigestion
bourg à 360 degrés
perrine et les membres de l'équipe de
france s'envole désormais vers les
championnats d'europe pour bosnie en
août prochain